[Music]
Adam yelling why did you select Joe as
your mentor for the season and look at
him ran out of people I guess he's got a
he's a beautiful man yeah I like pure
pure looks no I love him and have known
him a long time and now I love him even
more because now I feel like we've been
able to hang it on properly and he's
great and I think he would have thought
to be perfect so I'm you've worked with
tons of mentors on the show at seasons
13 what is Joe bringing to the table
this season specifically he offers good
advice and very sound advice and I trust
his opinion because I'm a fan it isn't
so I think that because we get along and
I we're definitely very like-minded in a
lot of ways like it makes it easier for
us to coach them together so Joe how the
experience been going for you it's been
great you know I think this is spoiling
me because everyone we've been able to
work with is really talented how do you
think you would have done if the voice
was around when you were starting off do
you think you could have made it on the
show oh yeah I would like to believe so
yeah I think for a lot of people you you
you cross your fingers set think I
probably can do it but what they're
going through is is really intense and
luckily they have great people to help
me belong the way